سقوط طائرات في جيني بريجوجين حيث ما يزال
الغموض يكتنف مصير قائد مجموعه
فاغنريفوجين اذ لم يتم حتى الان اعلان
موسكو رسميا مما يؤكد مقتل بريجوجين في
حادثه تحطم الطائره الخاصه الذي وقع مساء
امس وقالت هيئه النقل الجويه الروسيه ان
اسم بريجوجين كان مدرجا على قائمه ركاب
الطائره الخاصه التي كانت متجهه من موسكو
الى
ان جميع من كانوا على متنها قد لقوا حتفهم
وقد نقلت وكاله رايانوفوستي عن مسؤول في
اجهزه الطوارئ انه عثر في موقع تحطم
الطائره على ثمان جثث حتى الان
هذا واعلنت السلطات الروسيه عن اجراء
تحقيق في تحطم الطائره كانت مصادر روسيه
قد اشارت الى ان الطائره اختفت بعد 26
دقيقه من تحليقها وانها هبطت من ارتفاع 30
الف قدم الى ثمانيه الاف
وقالت مصادر اخرين طائره لدى سقوطها كانت
بجناح واحد
وقال مصدر سياسي في شركه فاجنر للجزيره ان
المجموعه وقياداتها تعتمد حاليا على
المعلومات الصادره من الجهات الرسميه بشان
تحطم الطائره فوق مقاطعه
المصدر الى انه من المفترض ان يكون
على متن الطائره اثناء عودته من افريقيا
الى سام بطرسبورغ عبر موسكو كما اكد انه
لم يتم التعرف على جثه ولكن عثر على هاتفه
بين الحطام وذكر المصدر ان بريجوجين كان
يغير رحلته في بعض الاحيان لكن الاحتمال
الاكبر انه كان على متن طائره التي تحطمت
وفي رده على سؤال عن اسباب الحادث قال
المصدر ان مجموعه فاغنر على تواصل مع
سلطات التحقيق وليس لديها تخمينات بشان
اسباب الحادث اما عن الشخصيات المتوقعه
لاداره المجموعه اشار المصدر لانهم الان
يعملون على حل القضايا التنظيميه
معنى من نصف مراسل الجزيره نور الدين نور
الدين طبعا نسال دائما عما اذا كان هناك
اي جديد
لحد الساعه لا يوجد اي جديد كل اخبار
تقريبا توقفت عند الاخبار الصادره عن هيئه
طيران وهيئه القضاء الجنائي فيما يخص
العمل على العمل على التحقيق والبحث في
ملابسه ما وقع وعون مساله هل بريكوجين
موجود ضمن القتلى قتله الطائره ام ان فقط
اسمه موجود على القائمه لكن ما هو اهم من
ذلك وهو الحديث عن شركه فاجنر ماذا تفعل
ماذا تنتظر ما طريقه عملها يمكن هنا
الحديث عن مجموعه من النقاط الاساسيه
النقطه الاولى وهي تتبع الشركه لمصير
رئيسها
ماذا حدث له الحد الساعه الشركه لا تزال
تتعامل وتتواصل مع الجهات الرسميه وتنتظر
ماذا يمكن ان تسفر عنه التحقيقات التي
تجريها سواء اداره الطيران المدني او
اداره القضاء الجنائي لمعرفه هذه
الملابسات وبالتالي هنا في انتظار اي موقف
لهذه المؤسسه وللاداره اداره هذه المؤسسه
يبدو انها تنتظر بشكل عملي
سيصدر من تحقيقات ومن نتائج هذه التحقيقات
اذا ما علمنا ان الاساس في كل هذا وهو
التقرير النهائي للطب الشرعي لكن هناك
نقطه قد تبدو اكثر اهميه وهو الحديث عن
عمل
مجموعه في الجانب الافريقي والالتزامات
العسكريه والامنيه التي لديها مع هذه
الدول بحسب الحديث مع مجموعه من
الهيئات التابعه لهذه المؤسسه يبدو
الانصباب الان والتوجه الان هو محاوله
ترتيب عمل المجموعه داخل الدول الافريقيه
خاصه الدول التي معروف ان مجموعه في هذه
المساله تنفيذ الالتزامات
استمرار عمل هذه المجموعه في ظل المتغيرات
الحاليه باعتبار ان المؤسسه هي مؤسسه
قائمه لها فروعها ولها هي اكلها وبالتالي
لا تريد بحسب الحديث هنا ان تتاثر بهذه
بما وقع في انتظار ما ستسترون عنه
التحقيقات
نحن نتحدث على ان الشركه تقول بانها تواصل
عملها تواصل تنفيذ التزاماتها مع المؤسسات
والدول التي هي متعاقده معها عمليا وفي
الشق العملي على مستوى متابعه ما حدث
للطائره يبدو ان فاجنر تحاول تنسيق مع
الجهات الامنيه والعسكريه والجهات الابحاث
والتحقيقات لمعرفه ملابسه مواقع والوصول
الى النتيجه النهائيه وفك اللغز والالتباس
الحاصل هل
كان موجود على الطائره او غير موجود على
الطائره لكن اذا ما حاولنا ان ننتقل الى
الشق الاساسي والشق المهم هو الشق الرسمي
هنا في روسيا كيف يتعامل مع هذا المستجد
بكل تاكيد هيئه الطيران تحاول بشكل او
باخر ان تنهي هذا التحقيق ومعرفه ماذا حدث
لهذه الطائره هل هي استهداف للطائره ام هي
خطا تقني خطا فني للطائره هناك حديث لشهود
عيان يقولون بانه عند
تحليق الطائره سمع عدوي انفجار بعد ذلك
ثلاث سقوط الطائره وهذا يفتح الكثير من
التكهنات هل هناك استهدفت هذه الطائره لا
احد هنا يؤكد ذلك بل هناك انتظار لما
ستسفر عنه العلبه السوداء او الصندوق
الاسود للطائره لحد الساعه لا حديث على ان
الصندوق تم العثور عليه لكن بكل تاكيد
باعتبار ان المساحه التي وقعت فيها
الطائره وسقطت فيها الطائره هي مساحه
مفتوحه وبالتالي هنا عمليا يسهل الحصول
على الصندوق الاسود اذا احدى المحددات
للوصول الى ماذا حدث للطائره هو الاعتماد
بشكل كبير جدا على الصندوق الاسود لكن بكل
تاكيد الهيئه تريد ان تفتح مسارات اخرى
للبحث والتحقيق فيما اذا كانت هذه الطائره
ربما لاسباب اخرى سقطت وهي الجانب الفني
المرتبط بطاقم الطائره الجانب المرتبط
بالاحوال الجويه والطقس الى اي مدى هل
تاثرت وكذلك جانب الارتباطات الرداريه
والاتصالات كل هذه العوامل هي مطروحه الان
على طاوله البحث والتحقيق لاعطاء تقرير
نهائي لكن السؤال دائما متى سيظهر هذا
التقرير ربما هذا يرتبط بمسير وطبي
العمليه البحثيه والتحقيقيه وهناك الاساسي
والمهم وهو ما سينتج عن تقرير الطب الشرعي
ماذا سيقول الطب الشرعي في الجثث التي تم
العثور عليها واخذها الى الطب الشرعي هل
سيصل الى نتيجه مفادها ان
موجود هناك بكل تاكيد عمليه البحث
والدائنه والبحث ربما هي من ستكشف هل فعلا
موجود او غير موجود لكن على مستوى الوثائق
الرسميه الحديث هنا انه كما كان موجود على
قائمه المسافرين لذلك الان يتم التعاطي
على انه موجود داخل طائره الى ان تثبت
نتائج الطب الشرعي صحه ذلك او عدمه نور
الدين بعيدا عن الرسميات في الداخل الروسي
كيف ينظر الى هذا الحادث
بكل تاكيد الجميع هنا يترقب خاصه حينما
نتحدث عن شخصيه مثل شخصيه هذه الشخصيه
الاشكاليه يمكن القول بان
الخلاف الذي وقع له مع وزاره الدفاع وكذلك
تمرده في جبهه الحرب مع اوكرانيا وكذلك
سيطرته على رستوف ومحاولته الوصول الى
موسكو بكل تاكيد هذا خلق نوعا من الجو هنا
داخل روسيا سواء من جهه ربما قد تكون
داعمه لتحرك بريكوجين او جهه رافضه للتحرك
بريكوجين لكن بكل تاكيد الجميع هنا ينتظر
ما ستسفر عنه التحقيقات خاصه بنسبه لهذه
الشخصيه الجدليه على المستوى الامني
والمستوى العسكري كذلك ربما الكثير هنا
ينظر الى انه الشخصيه التي استطاعت من
خلالها روسيا ان تصل الى الطرف الاخر من
العالم وهو القاره الافريقيه التي غابت
عنها روسيا وغابت عنهم منذ فتره
السوفياتيه الان تعود لها عن طريق
بريكوجن اذا بكل تاكيد هنا الشارع الصح
الاعلام السياسيين وكذلك النخب السياسيه
والنخب الامنيه بكل تاكيد تنتظر ماذا حدث
في هذه الحادثه وفي هذا السقوط للطائره هل
هو انتقام من بوتين ربما هنا الكثير يحاول
ان يستدل بالقول الذي ادلى به بوتين بعد
محاوله السيطره على التوجه الى موسكو
بالقول بان روسيا لا تسامح الخونه ربما هل
دخل بريكوجين في دائره الخونه وبالتالي
يمكن القول بانه كان هناك قرار للانتقام
من قبل الكرملين من بريكوجين ام ربما هو
الحادث عرضي لذلك الان الكل يترقب ليس
هناك اي موقف لا يمكن ليس هناك اي تصريح
من اي طرف ما ربما يعلن تاييد او معارضه
او تشكيك لكن بكل تاكيد الكل هنا ينتظر ما
ستسفر عنه هذه التحقيقات خاصه بشان شخصيه
كما اشرت هي شخصيه جدليه ربما خلال هذه
المده الوحيد ربما الذي اعلن التمرده بهذا
الشكل وتمرد من النوع العسكري وليس من
النوع السياسي الذي ربما شكل في وقته قلقا
للكرملين قلقا للجبهه الروسيه في مواجهه
اوكرانيا الان يتم الانتظار لمعرفه هل
فعلا العمليه هي عمليه انتقام ام هي سقوط
طبيعي لهذه الطائره بعدها ربما ستتبين
المواقف الشعبيه والسياسيه وكذلك العسكريه
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر نور الدين دغير مراسلنا
من موسكو